Europe needs to care for the things
people care about people care about the
future of our children and our society
culture and education are what linked
our history with our future this is what
makes us unique our soul our culture our
diversity our heritage and I know that
with Maria Gabriele it is in safe hands
this is why I'm happy to announce that
her portfolio will be renamed
Commissioner for innovation research
culture education and youth people care
about fairness and equality in every
sense of the word this is why I chose
Nicola Schmitt to be in charge of
implementing our European pillar of
social rights and fighting poverty from
childhood onwards he will put forward a
framework to ensure that every work in
our union has a fair minimum wage and we
have Janusz voice Tchaikovsky who will
ensure that our farmers can also thrive
as they adapt to new realities the train
transitions climate and digitalization
will bring changes for all but let us
there be no doubt farming will remain a
valued part of our culture and our
future we all know that one member of
our family intends to leave our union
a vast majority of this house seems to
be happy about the fact that a very very
very small group in this house would not
be able to clap as loud anymore and I've
never ever made any secret about the
fact that I will always be a remainer we
will respect the decision taken by the
British people we will work closely
together to find solution on common to
common challenges especially on security
measures but one he'll think has to be
absolutely clear whatever the future
holds the bond and the friendship
between our people are unbreakable Iliad
Emilio dura Pia Kissin gosh Paskus a
leborgne shows affair yes turkey service
teaspoon off of sailor community yes
Sookie Don Dahler top of Pontus Juan de
personaje will pour netway a parka yes
Sookie sock dollar mezzo sister Angela
still the vid for pot agility the junk
evil feral a difference news OC
Parliament can say a commission news OC
no new Devon faire la différence said on
30 speak Greek on stream only keeper
said on stratosphere kerchief is ICI
aujourd'hui the Volvo poor dimande votre
confianza metal news o travail I found
povedilla don't
Eagleman we've loved up aslim of oppa
long live Europe
[Applause]